an epoch that combines modern settings
and legendary heroes summoned from the
past duking it out for the artifact
known as the Holy Grail I'm sure you've
guessed what franchise I'm talking about
by now haven't you
if you did in you need to hang out on
the internet some more with how popular
the series has become it's about time we
have a video on the fate series and what
better topic to focus on than the fights
after all a war for the Holy Grails just
as good as the fights that set the stage
for the winners coronation on the other
hand who wouldn't want to take a trip
down memory lane and relive some of the
epic fights that you for table's known
for without further ado here are the top
10 fights in the fête anime series the
first heaven spiel movie ends in a bank
giving us our first fight on the list
rider vs. true assassin as the film
draws to a close
it seems that sabers master is doomed to
suffer the same fate as many who cross
true assassin yeah right you think
that'd kill the main character off
surprisingly help is on its way
just as she rose about to be finished
off by true assassin Rider of all
servants comes to the rescue and this
isn't the same rider as the one that was
easily defeated earlier in the movie
this time she's faster and more powerful
than her previous incarnation and she
puts on a show with her chains before
forcing a retreat out of true assassin
just how did a servant that was so weak
become the one to save our protagonist
it's anybody's guess at that point but
those familiar with the story know that
the answer is closer to Shiro than you
would have expected
[Music]
next up we have Archer versus Lancer in
unlimited blade works everyone knows him
for the jokes about him dying but when
you look at it from another perspective
Lancers probably one of the strongest
servants summoned in fate/stay night
holy grail war he constantly falls
victim to the biggest curse in anime
while fighting not being a main
character and even match battle quickly
goes in Lance's favor as he reveals that
he is indeed taking it easy in their
first confrontation with all the
shackles removed Lancer proves to be
without peer in combat and Archer finds
that out the hard way nevertheless both
combatants remain calm and collected as
Lancer unleashes his noble phantasm gay
bold a full-powered ro is barely
protected Archer from the powerful noble
phantasm may be GAE Bolg secretly the
most powerful noble phantasm in this war
once you hit by it game over the only
way to survive it is to defeat Lancer
beforehand and speaking of defeating
Lancer before he can use Gabe all
[Music]
next we have Lancer versus true assassin
to be honest I wouldn't consider this
much of a fight but more of a che see a
beautiful and cinematic chaise fitting
for a modern movie of the Fate franchise
seeing a pattern with short visually
pleasing fights in Heaven's feel when
you think about it the IT shows that
Lancer has the fight against true
assassin one in all the guards who
chases true assassins throughout the
city and he out maneuvers and overcomes
all the true assassin throws at him even
with superior combat abilities Lancer
fails to catch true assassin in time and
has led to a confrontation with the
shadow that's been haunting for yuuki
city seeing the threat of this new enemy
lancer attempts to use gay bulk but is
slain before managing to let loose the
destructive noble phantasm the fight is
here to showcase the threat of the
shadow and how a big player it is in the
story the look of disbelief on lances
face says it all no way would true
assassin be able to defeat a servant of
lances caliber but with the mysterious
shadow by his side masters and servants
beware
[Music]
our next entry is Shiro saber and rim
taking on Kazuki and Casta this fight
shows the while servants are the
mightiest heroes of legend you shouldn't
underestimate masters in a fight
Kazuki is one master who's trained
himself to fight on par with servants
and shows his strength by taking on
saver himself it isn't caster who
manages to overpower saber but her human
master something like that's unheard of
and it just shows how amazing a
combatant Kazuki's become with that
impressive showing against saber taking
down rim wouldn't be much of a chore now
would it
so it's up to Shiro to save the day and
boy did he do it he showcases his
projection abilities in his attempt to
save both saver and rin well creating
archers blades doesn't really get the
job done but the ability does shift the
tide of the battle a bit until Kazuki
and casts to make their getaway
[Music]
fate/zero has the next great fight on
the list Sabre vs. Lancer this fight
isn't the first to feature Sabre taking
on Lancer in the fate/zero timeline
previously Lancer always seemed to come
out on top
however the battles would always be
interrupted which results in a debatable
draw this time-saver and iris vo
confront Lancer for the last time hoping
to finish the duel between the servants
and finally decide a winner the two
servants exchanged blows as equals and
we see how much saber values fighting
with honor and a clear conscience
unfortunately further someone whose fate
is tied to her doesn't share her ideals
yep that fights cut short by Kira Tzu
goose intervention he coerced his
Kenneth to use his command seal in order
to force Lancer into committing suicide
with that Lancer dies cursing the holy
grail here at sugu and the world and
it's such a shame that such a good fight
ended in a tainted way then again all's
fair in love and war and keiretsu who's
the embodiment of that saying
at 5 we have saber alter vs. Berserker
from the second heaven spiel movie
midway through the second Heaven Steel
movie saber alter manifests and has none
other than Berserker as her first
opponent it's a key rematch from the
previous movie this battles Beek in a
way that it shows how far sabre in this
new form has come after losing to
Berserker in the original movie as her
previous self altar proves to be more
than what berserker and his numerous
lives can handle you can have a
physically besting Berserker as a claim
to fame but altar does it and more
seemingly unscathed by the raw power of
Berserker altar finishes the fight with
a new version of Excalibur overall the
fight might not be that exciting or
tense as the next ones that we have on
the list but it's a visual treat
[Applause]
Jonathan also higher token cos we don't
know I don't like hard on Ausmus honest
anatolia Nazi Germany
if there's a memorable moment in phase
zero due to the sheer spectacle of it
this would be it as the series
approaches its end were treated to a
final face-off between Rider and
Gilgamesh after some words to his master
ride activates his noble phantasm and
the fight song we once again get treated
the awesomeness that is IO neo hetero
who could be an entire army of soldiers
forged by bonds and the spirit of the
great Conqueror a red sword
that's what despite having his reality
marble wiped by Gilgamesh is a numeral
ish rider charges on enduring blade
after blade from the gates of Babylon
riders sheer willpower keeps him going
it's glorious for rider not not
confortable Ganesh but here he's finally
recognized as a worthy opponent to the
king of Heroes opening our top three is
Gilgamesh versus Shiro
honestly I'm tempted to put this fight
higher just because of the sheer
spectacle of it this fight in the climax
is largely one of the reasons why I like
unlimited blade works so much even with
the problems it has after seeing how big
of a karma Houdini Gilgamesh ended phase
zero as it feels so satisfying to see
him find his match in not the strongest
of servants but a boy who just really
really wants to be a hero of justice
using unlimited blade works shiro
manages to match Gilgamesh his sword
blow by blow as he admits this tactic
would be useless against the mightiest
servants but against the arrogant king
whose sword spams those he deems beneath
him this is the perfect counter shiro
outmaneuvers Gilgamesh is onslaught and
caps off the battle with his beautiful
version of roe is I'm sure that I'm not
the only one who had goosebumps in this
fight backed with in my opinion the best
rendition of the AMIA theme jamming in
the background this fight is a must
watch if you want something to convince
you to watch unlimited blade works this
is it
[Music]
in a close race for the top spot Archer
versus Shiro falls short in second place
they say your greatest enemy is yourself
that doesn't hit any closer to home for
both Shiro and Archer being Shiro's
future self from a timeline where he's
grown embittered and cynical Archer vows
to take down his other self and break
down the latter's details
what makes this battle so awesome is the
fact that it's not a battle of strength
come on we all know she rose a capable
fighter and that archers nowhere near
the strongest servant in terms of raw
power but do you think that Shiro has
any chance at all of defeating one of
the most resourceful and versatile
servants in a straight battle instead of
a battle of strength this battle is more
a clash of ideals Archer has the chance
to quickly put an end to his young naive
self but he refuses to do so his enemy's
not the boy in front of him but the
ideals that would soon turn that boy
into the cynic that he knows in the end
it's the stronger will that triumphed in
this battle refusing to give in to
archers taunts Shiro holds his ground in
his beliefs and grabs the victory that
he should never have gotten
[Music]
[Music]
so did you guess which fight made it to
the number one spot on our list yep
that's right key rate versus kiyotsugu
from fate/zero takes the number one spot
with key rate versus kyotsugu we have an
unorthodox fight for anime standards
with the past entries we've been treated
to amazing reality marbles excellent
swordsmanship and loads more
however this fight needs no such useless
fireworks
kirei and kyotsugu battle it out as
foils to people who are cut from the
same mold pragmatic monsters who are
beyond right or wrong in their personal
Crusades everything in the fight is what
you'd expect for a final battle between
two masters given fate/zero stellar
reputation fluid fight choreography and
brilliant strategizing highlight the
rather short confrontation between two
people who are essentially the same and
you could see in their exchanges despite
being this badass mage killer who
doesn't give a damn about fighting clean
and honorably cubed sugu finds his match
in the priest who acts as a wall that he
just can't overcome instead of a
slugfest were treated to a brilliant
dance of assassins personally this isn't
just my favorite from the Fate series
it's also one of my favorite fights in
anime period
and there we have it the top ten fate
anime fights do you know that the third
and final heavens filled movie is due
out next year that's right one more year
before it all ends with one hell of a
finale but wait we've barely covered the
thousands of spin-offs that the
franchise to spawn would you like to see
a part two for this video which includes
fights from the non UFO table series
like the video if so don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't and hit that
notification button so you never miss
any of our uploads I'll see you next
time on a vinny Tube trace off
[Music]